I believe that most human beings are
only living at about 40% of their
capability you know people didn't tell
us human I thought I came from outer
space man from some spacecraft and
landed down here and foreign Goggins
teamwork is big but I learned that you
have to be a good individual first need
motivation watching top 10 with believe
nation
what's that belief nation it's heaven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a man who went
from growing up in an abusive household
struggling in school and being
overweight to completing his Navy SEALs
training and becoming one of the
greatest endurance athletes in the world
he's David Goggins and here's my take on
his top ten rows a success volume 5 also
if you want to know what David has to
say about building unstoppable
confidence and excellence check out my
254 series where every day for the next
254 days I will send you a morning video
for free to help you build your
confidence the link to join are in the
description below you will never learn
from people if we always tap-dance
around the truth everything I didn't
want to do is what got me to where I'm
at today
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one make a new you you know people
didn't think I was human I thought I
came from outer space man from some
spacecraft and landed down here and
formed Goggins from the rocks and the
soil of the earth nas know how it is man
so I said yeah I wanna I want to share a
secret with you all
we're not talk to people like I see
where I'm at today but I know where I
come from and it's kind of hard to
almost separate that I'm almost not in a
way I'm kissing my own ass
but I'm amazed at what a human being can
actually do so I start talking myself in
the third person
it strictly because I know that I
literally made this human being out of
out of just like a whole bunch of scraps
mm-hmm and I wasn't you know I wasn't a
mechanic I wasn't a carpenter so I know
how to do anything you know I wasn't
trained and how to build a human being
from nothing you know like my mom didn't
training my dad didn't train me life in
the training well life blood trail yeah
life did train me correction and I
started putting this scrap metal
together like I want to happen you know
the first shot I do is off up after I
start learning more and more and more
through pain and suffering so I'm
learning or just learning so much about
stuff before I knew it man I've built
this beautiful card I'm like how that I
do that and I knew how to knit and I
know how to do it because I have all the
tools do all the failure I went through
trying to build this person who's
mccoggins well number two get in charge
of your brain I believe that most human
beings are only living at about 40
percent of their capability so the mine
has a governor like a car if you're
driving a car and the car has a governor
on it the car may say hundred thirty
miles an hour but the governor set 491
once that governor sets in you get the
91 that car starts doing this the car
wants to go the car wants to go but that
factory said uh-uh
we're not going past 91 we have a
factory a nice governor in our brain and
it's a survival mechanism it protects us
from
pain and suffering the second we feel
that our mind says no no this isn't fun
we should back off we should sit down
find something more comfortable and
there's some about the mind the mind has
the tactical advantage over you at all
times
at all times of your life the mind has a
tactical advantage over you why is that
it knows what you're afraid of it knows
your insecurities it knows your deep
dark lies and it starts to push you away
from that it pushes you in a direction
that is comfortable the mind controls
everything so what I realized was that
when I was growing up and I was 300
pounds and I got all fat and I got all
insecure I realized that my mind kept
taking me in this direction when things
got uncomfortable for me when I was
facing my insecurities I was facing my
fears my mind said oh no we have the
tactical advantage we just get you
separate you from this feeling this
feeling over your life's all about
feelings we want the happy feeling we
don't want that feeling if this sucks
why am I here and you don't have any
choice or you can't answer those
questions so you leave I started
realizing that if in that moment you can
answer those tough questions and you are
now in charge of your brain versus your
brain ruling you that's where all that
stuff comes from so the 40% rule is all
of that you get to 40% your brain says
we're done let's roll man this is trying
to get painful this is uncomfortable so
you sit down you have to figure out ways
and everybody's different that's how the
book kind of talks about like we all
have these things about you know five
steps to this and four steps to this
it's it's a lot more than that that's
all [ __ ] it's it's a practice that
you have to it's a habit so if you know
that forty percent I'm still you know
I'm feeling pain at 40 percent feeling
pain that's where the 40 percent rule
kicks in now it starts okay I'm feeling
pain my mind's saying all this to me
it's saying get out of here run flee the
fight-or-flight kicks in okay we're
gonna we're not good enough and starts
telling you all these things you start
to believe it because the mind controls
all this is the time
got the game control back of your mind
it's okay let me see if I can go 45% and
once you start giving yourself more and
more hope and start realizing okay the
mine starts to be okay what are you
doing we're supposed to be going right
and you're going left you start then
controlling your mind start finding more
in you know in yourself and it goes from
40% to a lot further than that but
that's the start of it though get to get
to the spot where your mind is saying
stop wherever that is yeah get there
first and then that's when that starts
to work for you you got to control
yourself in that moment rule number
three develop discipline so I prioritize
trying to win the battle in the morning
so I always win the battle of mourning
so I get morning time every morning I go
for a run that's the first thing I do
every morning haven't taken a day off of
running since December 2016
I've every day up in the morning so I
also stretch out every day for about two
or three hours every day I've missed two
days and about five and a half six years
so that's just my routine and about four
days a week I'm in the gym hitting the
weights cuz you know you can't just be a
runner so this is every single day the
the monotony of my life but this is what
builds discipline you know and not
everybody I'm not telling everybody to
do this but this is my lifestyle this is
how I build self-discipline rule number
four do the impossible you made this
decision to self publish this book yes
sir right now it's out like number two
or number three on Amazon of all books
all right all right that just doesn't
happen with a self-published book well
that's been the story of my life I I see
something that's that's quite off quite
not the same and that's what I go for
I've just that this book is exactly who
I am as a person exactly the way I did
this book is harder my almost my entire
life as I see what is not the norm
what's impossible with we know all the
theorists say you shouldn't be doing
this that's the wrong way to go and I'm
like
hmm let me see if I can pull this door
rule number five face the real you a lot
of people could live with themselves
look in the mirror and say I'm okay with
being afraid I'm okay with going on this
easy highway over here the easy highway
has all these signs and directions had
to get somewhere and you have to first
be uncomfortable with how you feel about
yourself with that voice that loud most
like to run away from we all have it we
all have that voice and say hey man you
know you're you're kind of wimping out
right now you kind of be a little punk
right now but I would say okay that's
okay it's okay to tell you little white
lies to ourselves so you first have to
face the real you the real me is David
Goggins the real me is a guy looking at
you right now saying I don't want to be
on this show right now because I used to
stutter as a kid and I'm afraid of that
I'm afraid that here in a second
I'm gonna start stammering a stutter and
the whole world is gonna know that I
have all these issues but that's when I
see right now okay Goggins you got to go
on this show that's Goggins Goggins is
saying okay David Goggins you're a punk
life made you this way we can't live
like this we can't live in fear we can't
live in judgment we can't be afraid of
what the people right now are looking at
me saying about me we cannot be afraid
of that
that's Goggins Goggins saying all of you
who don't like me who don't want to in
that person then it comes in but you
have to be David Goggin to say man I'm
afraid of this I'm up here
life made me this way here I stutter
I have these issues with reading and
writing and and I'm fat and I'm insecure
you have to face that in that dark room
in that dark room is who you are but in
that dark room is where you have to
create another human being that walks
out of that dark room to face who you
are that's the only way you're gonna get
over all those things you have to create
someone else not like you have two
different personalities it is you but
you have to find strength in that
visualization of almost me cracking out
Goggins
like almost like that Superman cape like
coming out a different person a person
that doesn't give about anything who
doesn't care about being judged who
knows I'm weak who knows I'm afraid
who says whatever you think about me
take it whatever I'm here
that's guidance in the dark room you
face yourself you realize you want to be
better you realize you don't want to be
this weak insecure person in the world
has all these problems that we all have
we all have souls of me is a great
platform to tell you who we want to be
now who we are so that's where that dark
room is rule number six be a good
individual first what are some of the
most valuable things you learned in the
Navy
you'd be it about yourself or you know
what some of the most available things a
lot people say teamwork and stuff like
that teamwork is big but I learned that
you have to be a good individual first
you have to triple down on your
weaknesses because a lot of times like
you always count on your buddy
next to you to help you out sometimes
that buddy's not going to be there you
got to make sure that you are a jack of
all trades and a master of all trades
and that's one thing you got you gotta
have your buddies back they can have
your back but you've got to work on
yourself every single day rule number
seven do the things you don't like I'm
not a big guy on social media I mean
it's not big on that stuff even today
I'm just not a big fan of it ma'am I'm a
big introvert I get a lot of my strength
from being introverted and I'm going out
there and do what I do is very all this
is very difficult for me man
oh I don't what do you have like six
hundred thousand-plus on Instagram yeah
yeah and for somebody who's you're
averse to it you don't like it you hate
it you only post once in a while you
don't really advertise what you're doing
at all but your own this huge following
of people who are super interested in
what you're doing well I think it's
important to do things they don't like
and I am I was very ashamed in my life
story for a long time
III didn't want to go out and tell
anybody about me so that's why I had two
people I you know I created one david
Goggins and one Goggins right and i
didn't want people to know that
I had all these issues but after a while
people start to give you these different
tag lines you know like you're
superhuman you're amazing they start
right you don't know anything about me
man I'm this insecure kid I start
realizing there's a lot of people out
here who are going through a lot of
problems that I once tapped into you
know I had a whole bunch of she's
growing up and you know I I felt
compelled to dish you know what you got
to start sharing this stuff man cuz
people see where you're at today they
see where you're at today they they see
the man you are today this this hard
rock hard human being show these people
where you come from
right so many people as possible rule
number ain't get real with yourself
there's my junior year in high school
and I fell back a lot I fell back in
this whole of life the second you think
that you've overcome it you climbed
Everest you're on that last hold and
life was saying not today you know push
you down and my junior in high school
I missed a whole bunch of school was
lying my mom have like a 1 point
something GPA I was just jacked up I
mean it was I was in when one of the
worst parts of my life and my mom was
going to college too and shouldn't have
time to sit back and baby me
and it was me against me my pants were
down to my knees I was just I was not
whatever was going on I was in a bad
shape so I went to the bathroom and I
had this weird haircut because I wanted
attention I was an attention getter I
went to an all-white school pretty much
some of the kids like me allowed and
didn't like me whatever then it matter I
was looking for something so I dressed
differently crazy haircuts and I went to
the mirror and the reflection and it
revealed a lot of bad things a lot of
things that I was hiding behind the
saggy pants and I'm looking at myself in
the mirror going like God dog dude you
gotta you are something else man like
you have created a character I want to
be the cool guy table and whatever I
could do to get attention I did it
wasn't me it wasn't who I was inside but
I was scared for anybody know who I was
inside so in that kind of building
mirror I call it
got real myself I said you have a third
grade reading level which is hard to
admit when you're a junior in high
school that you copied on every single
thing you give because of fear they're
gonna put me in a special school we all
know what special means I don't have a
title on myself the rest my life and
being cool you don't have a title on
yourself
so I started cheating I was dumb and
people say oh he's no you learn
disability
I don't learn this to believe I realized
I was lazy so I called myself out there
I called myself out every which way
possible I called myself I was as honest
I was honest look at yourself man
look at yourself and it was that day in
a couple of days after that I just got
real myself and every day I came home I
called the accountability mirror what am
I gonna do today to change what I see in
this mirror what am I gonna do today and
a lot of it was I stopped sit with the
cool guys I actually took my shirt in
with the school looking like a man this
I'm gonna look if you don't like it so
be it
I had to really wear this this this
layer of skin I had to develop a really
callous skin on me there to take
whatever you're gonna call me you're
gonna call me whatever I'm gonna be I
want a geek but whoever I am you're
gonna see me you're gonna see me for who
I am because I need to change who I'm
not and that accountability member just
became wrong and I became fat over the
years guys fell back in the hole I
called myself fat because I was fat and
people don't want to do that they want
to say oh don't call yourself fat don't
call yourself dumb if you're not real
and raw with who the you are nothing's
gonna change in this nice new world that
we live in we want to hear you're just a
little big no man you might be fat and
it's okay to hear that from yourself
infra Maribel's so that's where it
started at and it's raw it gets ugly
sometimes with me in that mirror but I'm
also proud of myself to be able to tell
myself that and then fix what's in that
mirror rule number nine take on
challenges while spraying for
cockroaches
the air force spraying for cockroaches I
was about to 97 to be exact
and I saw this Discovery Channel show on
TV and I was like and that discovery
challenge so was this guys going through
hell week and I saw these guys freezing
a lot of water and I was like you know
what it brought back memories of me
going through peer rescue training so at
297 pounds I decided to try to be a Navy
SEAL and to make a long story short I
had to lose 106 pounds in less than
three months and that's where it became
challenging for me so I knew to lose 106
pounds in less than three months you're
looking at 3,500 calories
it's a pound so I was basically doing a
whole bunch of math in my head so I knew
if I were to stop and be stagnant there
was no calories being burned so I just
basically trained all day long so I saw
it went and before I knew it I've lost
the weight and rule number 10 the last
one me for a very special bonus clip and
stay hard well it's that time of year
again we start to feel real happy why
because we're not going to work if you
believe in Santa Claus and you celebrate
Christmas we looking forward to Santa
Claus coming down the chimney giving you
some presents it's a real good time of
year so in a good time of year we start
to feel real good about ourselves so I
start to feel great so we start making
promises to ourselves about hey I'm
going to lose some weight I'm going to
do better in school I'm gonna be better
here to be better there but guess what
happens the real Merry Christmas happens
with all of that noise is gone it's
quiet and it's you against you and now
all those endorphins are gone and I
promise you made by getting up early and
getting after to go lose weight study
harder guess what it's like harder now
that repetition becomes a lot harder now
so labas can't do things on their own so
find somebody in your life so when you
throw that towel in they throw that back
at you and say you're not done yet stay
true to yourself stay hard
now I'm going to stretch a bone escape
from David on how to get rid of
negativity that I think you're really
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
time to move from just watching another
video to taking action in your life for
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go
question number one what challenge do
you need to take on number two what do
you need to get real with yourself on
and number three what does make a new
you look like for you as you're trying
to fix yourself and dig yourself out of
this deep hole that life Society and you
helped you helped also those people who
you saw down there in that hole who were
there with you who your friends and
people who you counted on because you
meet the people in the same situation
that you're in in life those people
becomes your friends and second you try
to get out of that situation become
better those people and that in that
grave and that does this yanking at your
heels man saying oh no get no come on
back here yeah you ain't gonna make me
feel like you getting out of this hole
through the do you think you are so I
get that all the time now people were
constantly remind me of who I used to be
back in the day
if you want more David Goggins
motivation check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there so I got it I got put that people
get their butt hurt so not everybody
most of this generation quits the second
they get talked to